welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Matt Murdock recently revealed that
the sokovia Accords had been repealed in
She-Hulk episode 8 causing many people
on the internet to wonder if a second
superhuman Civil War is on the horizon
for the MCU well my beautiful nerd
babies how would you feel if I told you
that the seeds for an MCU adaptation of
the comic book Civil War 2 storyline
could have been planted years ago in
Captain America 2 that could potentially
lead us into a Civil War 2 scenario for
Captain America five well let's talk
about its speculation Nation because
I've got some speculating to do but
first do not forget to hit up the
rockstarsmerch.com today to pick up our
latest Obsession shirts inspired by both
geook and House of the Dragon like
She-Hulk just ended guys so like our
shirt is going away very soon so pick up
our She-Hulk latest Obsession shirt
today while you still can alright so
much like the MCU has adapted the Civil
War comic storyline for the third
Captain America movie I believe that
they will do the same for a Sam Wilson
Captain America five and yes I know what
you guys may be thinking hold on MD why
are we even talking about Captain
America five when we haven't even seen
the red white and Birdman throw a
freedom frisbee out of green geek's
freaky forehead in Captain America 4 New
World Order huh well that is a fantastic
question internet stranger and I think
that knowing that the leader is going to
be the villain of Captain America New
World Order gives us a massive hint as
to what Marvel Studios could have in
store for a Civil War 2 in the MCU and
listen guys today's video is sponsored
by Babel one of the top language
learning apps in the world my home city
has a huge Dia de los Muertos event
coming up and it looks super cool I
really want to go but what I don't want
to do is show up and be the only person
who doesn't understand what's going on
which happens very frequently in my life
that's what Babble is for Babel
specializes in preparing you for real
life Encounters in situations remember
those I don't Studies have shown that 15
hours of using Babel is the equivalent
of a semester of college Spanish which
is a bang for your buck in 15 hours in
Babel just flies by like I can watch
videos listen to podcasts play games or
do lessons whatever kind of learning
mood that I'm in Babel's got something
that fits the bill I really like how
they gamify learning I have daily goals
and achievements that I can unlock as I
learn the language like I'm pretty early
in my Babel Journey but I have started
to learn some useful phrases like estoy
muerto and Este seguro get up to 60 off
your subscription when you click the
link in the description to start
learning with Babel today we thank
battle for sponsoring this video you
guys are awesome a second Civil War why
well it's because I believe the leader
will be helping the greatest enemy to
the Captain America mantle that there is
Hydra because like I explained in a
recent video breaking down what the New
World Order is from the Marvel Comics
The New World Order organization was
originally started by The Red Skull in
order to coordinate the efforts of the
Earth's most powerful and influential
villains in order to slowly take over
the world from the Shadows calling their
sketchy shadowy group the villain
equivalent to the United Nations now
knowing that we we could see the
Resurgence of hydro in Captain America 4
after Steve Rogers took them down and
Captain America the Winter Soldier I
believe that Hydra could very well be
picking up where they left things off in
Captain America 2. but this time with
the leader to fast-track their progress
because if you remember from Captain
America 2 Hydro was using an algorithm
that Microsoft Zola made that could
predict people's future actions by
analyzing their past actions and they
called Zola's little science project
project Insight a project that Hydra was
going to use to give their helicarriers
the coordinates a potential future
threats in an algorithm that was so good
that it even predicted the rise of
Doctor Strange before he even came on
the scene and in that same movie Zola
does note that hydra's main goal after
they lost in World War II was to create
calculated chaos in order to usher in
their own form of order hydra's order a
new world order for 70 years Hydra has
been secretly feeding crisis weeping war
and when history did not cooperate
story was changed Hydra created a word
so chaotic that humanity is finally
ready to sacrifice its freedom to gain
its security
once purification process is complete
hydra's New World Order will arise
however since we know that Steve Rogers
exposed the hell out of hydra's future
predicting project Insight in Captain
America the Winter Soldier it's not
surprising that Hydra would choose to
potentially work with Tim Blake Nelson's
the leader as the character in the
comics is known for being a future
predicting human computer to an
astonishing degree especially since
canonically the leader has been in
hydra's position ever since Black Widow
arrested him into Shield custody after
he was babbling about building an
illustrious future defined by power and
influence a feature that I believe the
leader is helping Hydra create by
Reviving project Insight in his own
image now how does this all tie into
Civil War Two you may be wondering well
if you've already read the event from
the comics then you are already well
familiar with how that event was
basically Marvel comics's Minority
Report and I loved it so much for that
fact hello because an inhuman by the
name of Ulysses Kane emerged out of
nowhere with the power to see the future
and as soon as the super powered Heroes
of the MCU found out that the world now
had a way to see future threats before
they happened they all started to be
split as to whether or not it was
morally right to stop crimes before they
happened with Carol damage aside wanting
to use Ulysses to get the jump on bad
guys and Tony starkside being 100
against arresting people before crime
was even committed which is what Carol's
side sort of ends up doing and boom
there you have it we've got ourselves a
second superhuman Civil War now this all
being said and seeing as the Inhumans
don't seem to be the plan for the MCU
for a long while at least I don't see
the MCU using the inhuman precogulysses
to predict the future but rather the
leader's new algorithm that he'd be
designing for Hydra based on his own
mind because again now that Hydra cannot
use Zola's algorithm in the same way if
they wanted to after their plans got
foiled in cap two it would make sense
that they opt for the newest generation
of mad scientists in the form of the
evolved gamma-powered mind of the leader
because guys I truly believe that the
aftermath of Captain America fighting
the leader in New World Order could have
a massive potential to usher in the
Civil War II conflict because of these
factors because if you've got a Captain
America movie literally named after a
hydro organization called New World
Order with a villain that can see the
future it just screams project insights
2.0 to me and whether that means the
creation of a new algorithm by the
leader or even the heroes and or
governments of the MCU wanting to use
the leader himself as the future seeing
Catalyst I believe that Captain America
5 could be a continuation of the
franchise's story on the dangers and
temptations of being able to see the
future but only time will tell see what
it did there but thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at Master attainment on Twitter if
you want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ]
and really fun theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on the internet that if
you're 18 years and older you can just
search for new rockstars on Discord just
join the Discord conversation today and
again do not forget to hit up new
roxasmerch.com to pick up our latest
tester shirts inspired by She-Hulk and
House of the dragon or any of our other
amazing nerd options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com but again thank you
guys so much for watching this video I
love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]